Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich sage hallo zu allen hier. Am neunten.
Neunten April zwanzig einundzwanzig und es ist Freitag und das heißt es ist Corona Weekly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Ja, da hatten wir Ostern hinter uns gelassen und es ist das passiert mit dem wir schon gerechnet haben.
Nichts. Es ist nichts passiert,
Und über diese Woche sollen wir jetzt berichten. Ich war auch selbst so ein bisschen in so einem Recherche-Pflege mal. Äh dir ging's glaube ich ein bisschen anders, aber ich äh
dann auch irgendwann so eine so eine innere Ermattung äh gespürt, wo ich jetzt gerade keinen Bock hatte, jeder Studie hinterherzurennen, die,
die mir im Beitrag nicht auf den Bäumen waren.
Aber so insgesamt hatte ich auch so den Eindruck, hat sich so im Großen und Ganzen an der Gesamtsituation so nichts ähm getan, beziehungsweise politisch hat sich nicht viel getan.
Die Zahlen waren so ein bisschen hm was soll man jetzt davon halten.
Und von daher denke ich, werden wir uns heute mal die Zahlen mal ganz genau anschauen, um mal zu verstehen, was da eigentlich gerade passiert oder was da eigentlich gerade nicht passiert.
Ja. Ja, wir hatten ja äh schon damit gerechnet und alle haben eigentlich damit gerechnet, dass Ostern so ein bisschen wie Weihnachten ähm eben unsere Zahlenerfassung aus dem T.
Bringt und das ist ein Stück weit auch passiert, so dass wir.
Jetzt noch ein bisschen Mühe haben zu unterscheiden, inwieweit sich denn jetzt äh faktisch Schulschließungen und,
auch reduziert,
Aktivität ähm in den Büros und an den an den Arbeitsplätzen über Ostern, das haben halt viele natürlich genutzt äh so, um auch Urlaub zu nehmen. Das sieht man auch ganz gut an den Mobilitätswerten
dass,
die halt beim bei den Arbeitsplätzen auch über Ostern stark eingebrochen sind. Das heißt, wir haben die Situation auf der einen Seite,
hat es in bestimmten Bereichen,
deutlich weniger Kontakte gegeben in anderen Bereichen, im privaten hat es halt möglicherweise mehr Kontakte gegeben, also Leute waren auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr zu Hause,
und ja das müsste eigentlich auch eine reale Auswirkung äh auf die Zahlen gehabt haben plus,
Was aber dann auch dazu kommt ist, dass natürlich über die Feiertage dann Leute gerade die jetzt nicht vielleicht so schlimm betroffen sind oder nicht so.
Symptomen leiden, dann tendenziell eher zu Hause bleiben und sich nicht testen lassen oder nicht zum Arzt gehen, weil der halt zu ist, sind sie nicht irgendwie jetzt in die Notaufnahme wollen oder so, das heißt,
dass äh,
bringt die Zahlen dann eben auch ähm sagen künstlich ein bisschen runter, wobei das dann sein kann, dass die Leute Benzin dann schlechter geht oder wenn dann die Ärzte wieder aufhaben.
Sich dann melden und getestet werden, das heißt man erwartet dann eigentlich so einen gewissen Nachholeffekt äh der jetzt auch gerade äh
auftritt und ja Nachholeffekt äh und äh.
Reale Auswirkungen jetzt, also wie ist das reale Infektionsgeschehen.
Und neben den reinen Institzen haben wir da ja noch,
die äh äh positiven Quote so auf die man immer einen Blick werfen kann, die hinkt
leider zeitlich eben immer ein bisschen hinterher, weil ähm
Ja äh die eben die Tests nur immer wöchentlich so erfasst werden und dann einmal die Woche ausgewertet werden, sodass wir die die ganz,
neuen Zahlen noch nicht haben, sondern nur wenn man nur die Zahlen bis KW,
bis einschließlich KW dreizehn und die ging bis zum vierten vierten. So und.
Da muss man.
Leider konstatieren ähm gehen die Zahlen bisher äh also bei der geht die positiven Quote weiter,
nach oben und ist zwischendurch auch nach oben gegangen, um zu sagen in der in der Woche davor
obwohl dort deutlich mehr Tests gemacht wurden und über Ostern sind es aber auch die Testrate um achtzehn Prozent wieder wieder eingebrochen auf eins Komma eins fünf Millionen,
während äh ja äh wir äh dann aber bei der positiven Quote jetzt,
äh in der NRK dreizehn eben bei elf Komma null sechs.
Prozent gerade angekommen sind. So von neun Komma drei drei in der Vorwoche. Das heißt,
Bei den Tests ist bisher noch nicht sichtbar geworden äh das über Ostern.
Irgendwas zurückgegangen ist, obwohl es eigentlich zurückgegangen sein müsste oder oder könnte, äh sagen wir mal so.
Da das jetzt viel auch immer wieder in solchen äh Hinweisen auf diesen Wert äh ins Feld geworfen wird. Wie siehst du denn diesen Einfluss, der jetzt so.
Häufiger stattfindenden Schnelltests auf diese ganze Zahlenreihe.
Ja ähm,
Weiß nicht, ob wir das mit den Tests äh jetzt schon äh aufmachen wollen, aber äh gut im Zusammenhang jetzt, okay. Äh eine Frage ist halt immer, wie wirken sich jetzt die Schnelltests
möglicherweise auf die positiven Rate aus und dann gibt's eben auch,
Hypothese, sage ich mal, das jetzt, wenn viele Leute viele asymptomatische gerade Schnelltests machen, die dann
positiv äh anschlagen, dass die
dann eben auch anschließend einen PCR-Test machen, den sie ohne die Schnelltests nie gemacht hätten, weil äh ja die Symptome nicht ausgeprägt genug oder gar nicht vorhanden waren und sie sonst gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen wären
und dass das gewissermaßen die Vortestwahrscheinlichkeit erhöht,
das ist jetzt schwierig zu quantifizieren, weil wir keine Zahlen darüber haben, wie viele Schnelltests eigentlich durchgeführt werden tatsächlich
Was man aber auch häufiger hört ist, dass die Schnelltests.
Oft kaum positive liefern, also ich habe jetzt schon von mehreren Fällen.
Gehört wo über tausend Tests gemacht wurden und niemand oder nur eine Person gefunden wurde, so bei tausend Tests. Was.
Irgendwie,
ja nicht nicht stimmen kann eigentlich, das das passt dann wieder nicht zu den Parametern oder zu der Performance von den Tests und was man dann hört ist.
Dass auch die Tests oft so durchgeführt werden, gerade bei Kindern,
So ja nicht so tief in die Nase rein, ja? Nur
ganz vorsichtig irgendwie vorne so ein bisschen und dann aus Angst sich vielleicht anzustecken, wird das dann eben schnell äh ja irgendwohin
geträufelt und das heißt,
viele der Tests offenbar auch so durchgeführt werden, dass man tatsächlich versucht möglichst kein positives Ergebnis äh hinzubekommen. Das wurde mir äh zumindest auch.
Berichtet und ich halte das für plausibel. So, weil wer will schon einen positiven Test äh äh.
Ja. Weil das führt dann nur zu Hesse und dann äh ja Ärger und Problem und ja ne das geht nicht ja ähm.
Insofern äh ja kann ich die Frage leider nicht wirklich quantitativ beantworten wie.
Die Auswirkungen auf die Testzahlen sind, aber.
Ist es ohnehin so, dass unsere Dunkelziffer jetzt nicht so super hoch ist und die eigentliche Frage ist, inwieweit,
Leuchten jetzt diese Tests des Dunkelfeld äh etwas weiter aus und da bin ich,
ehrlich gesagt skeptisch hier und da äh mag das der Fall sein, aber generell kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen,
dass das äh jetzt einen sagenden,
anhaltenden Anstieg der positiven Rate zur Folge,
normalerweise ist es so letztlich ist eine Änderung im Testregime.
Die die vortestwahrscheinlichkeit ändert und damit dann auch einen Einfluss auf die positiven Quote.
Hat, aber solche Effekte tendieren dazu, sich mit der Zeit äh auszunehvidieren. Das heißt, wenn du was änderst am Testregime, dann hast du halt.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier Wochen.
Eine Veränderung der Zahlen aber nicht über einen wesentlich längeren Zeitraum dann verschwindet der Effekt irgendwann, weil es stabilisiert sich eben eben wieder
Und ja, da ist von der Stabilisierung gerade nichts zu sehen.
Außerdem hat ja die positiven Quote ohnehin einen extremen Nachlauf, ne? Also wäre schon mehrfach gesagt, so positiven Quote äh zeigt so ein bisschen auch.
Den Verlauf der äh Pandemie an. Aber da da ist ja ohnehin ein sehr gedämpfter Wert.
Der der eben nicht so stark schwankt mit mit all diesen ganzen Einflüssen.
Wenn man ihn sich so im Nachhinein anschaut. Und von daher könnte man fast auch annehmen, dass die positiven Quote auch solche Schwankungen irgendwie in sich in sich aufnimmt. Warum sollte sich das jetzt auf einmal ändern.
Na wir haben gut wir haben wie gesagt auch deutliche Schwankungen eben in der in der Zahl der Tests und.
Komischerweise eben in der KW elf.
Also elf und zwölf jeweils noch einen Anstieg und dann in der KW dreizehn wieder.
Ein Abfall auf äh ja die normalen eins Komma eins Millionen, die wir halt jetzt dieses Jahr im Schnitt so haben,
Also so viel zu den zu den Tests, ja es ist unklar, aber wenn der, aber der Effekt äh ist.
Wird nicht sehr groß sein und wenn einer da ist, müsste der sich aber irgendwann dann einpendeln, sage ich mal.
Gut, dann würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten, der starke Anstieg der positiven Quote verheißt eigentlich nichts Gutes.
Nein, tut er nicht äh aktuell in der Tat. Ja.
Und wenn wir um um den vielleicht jetzt auch mal einen ein paar Zahlen dann zu nennen. Hm.
Wo wir denn jetzt, wo wir denn jetzt aktuell stehen. Ähm so wir sind, glaube ich, ja, jetzt jetzt kommt wieder das das Problem.
Mit den verschiedenen ähm Messungen der Institanz. Hm.
Dass er viele Stammhörer schon kennen,
werden denn eigentlich gibt es mindestens zwei Institzwerte, die normalerweise, wenn alles gut läuft mit der Datenerfassung.
Wenn die Gesundheitsämter ja gut arbeiten, dann liegen die Werte sehr eng beieinander, aber.
So manchmal läuft's eben auch auseinander, wenn's dann zu,
so Nachholeffekten kommt oder die Zahlen sich rasch ändern und quasi mit dem veröffentlichen nicht hinterher kommen. So und jetzt.
Sagen die offizielle sieben Tage Instit für Deutschland nach.
Eben Meldedatum, das was das RKI auch macht, sind jetzt hundertzehn Komma vier,
pro einhunderttausend Einwohnern,
gemeldet wurden allerdings in den letzten Tagen hunderteinundzwanzig Komma sieben Fälle pro hunderttausend ja also irgendwo.
Zwischen den beiden Werten, sage ich mal, bewegt sich dann die.
Die tatsächliche Institution unabhängig von von zeitlichen Schwankungen, also hundertzehn bis hundertzwanzig kann man sagen, sind wir gerade und.
Unter hundert äh ist je nachdem auch welche der beiden Institenzen man heranzieht sind halt entweder,
Ja eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs Länder, wenn man.
Die RKI-Institenz nimmt und drei Länder, wenn man die Institut nach publizierten Fällen äh sich anschaut. Ja und.
Der berühmte RWT.
Berechnet jetzt auf der Basis der Neuinfektion der letzten zwei Wochen.
Bei null Komma neun eins auf Basis der publizierten Fälle.
Und null Komma neun null auf Basis der Fälle nach Meldedachtum, also liegt halt äh.
Beieinander.
Und auch bei den Bundesländern mit Ausnahme, grade von Saarland und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hm ist der RWT aktuell unter eins.
Also die Zahlen gehen in vielen Ländern gerade noch zurück, muss man sagen.
Im, wie gesagt, gemittelt, aber äh schaut man sich jetzt einfach nur den den sieben Tage Durchschnittswert,
an, dann hat der gerade gestern wieder äh erstmalig einen Knick gemacht und steigt wieder.
So
Die eigentliche Frage, die uns doch jetzt die ganze Zeit quält ist, sind das jetzt tatsächliche Ostereffekte es in,
Die Schulen haben zu und es wird weniger gearbeitet und deswegen gehen die Zahlen auch real zurück. Oder ist es ein Ostereffekt im Sinne von
Die Gesundheitsämter machen auch äh gerade äh weniger oder melden weniger oder kriegen weniger gemeldet, weil die Labore weniger arbeiten. Also haben wir da quasi den Ausfall der überprüfenden
meldenden Seite.
Also ist 'ne Mischung aus beiden wie groß der Anteil ist, ist.
Nicht ganz so leicht zu sagen, das werden wir dann am am am Ende sehen, aber ich denke, wir haben's durchaus äh schon mit einem echten Rückgang zu tun durch Ostern,
aber nicht so ausgeprägt wie äh das jetzt der Blick auf die Kurve erscheinen lässt
aber auch der Nachholeffekt gerade lässt noch so ein bisschen
auf sich warten, also im Prinzip müssen wir da eine noch eine eine Woche warten, bis wir da das endgültige Urteil fällen können
ja aber dadurch dass ja die die Zahlen jetzt schon wieder steigen.
Zerrinnt langsam auch die Hoffnung, dass wir jetzt durch Ostern.
Wirklich die endgültige Trendwende eingeleitet haben könnten oder die dritte Welle jetzt.
Gebrochen bis und äh auf jeden Fall haben wir eine kleine Verschnaufpause äh bekommen beziehungsweise die Zahlen.
Steigen nicht so schnell wie sie ohne Ostern wahrscheinlich gestiegen wären,
aber ja die Verschnaufpause ist wahrscheinlich kurz, das hat uns vielleicht eine Woche oder zwei jetzt gebracht
vielleicht auch drei Wochen, aber das ist natürlich auch auch wertvoll so. Ne, das ist, ich sage mal, ich freue mich,
über jeden Rückgang,
äh egal wie kleiner sein mag, weil äh oder selbststagnation ist halt zumindest kein Wachstum.
Aber wie du auch, glaube ich, vorhin schon gesagt hattest, die Zahlen in den Krankenhäusern äh auf den Intensivstationen.
Entwickeln sich äh ja unschöner oder oder bedrohlicher als äh jetzt die reinen Fallzahlen.
Und das hat möglicherweise auch den Hintergrund, dass die neuen Varianten einfach.
Gefährlicher sind, also dass die B eins eins sieben im für mehr Hospitalisierung äh sorgt
und äh für schwerere Symptome bei bei vielen und auch äh für möglicherweise mehr Todesfälle, sodass wird noch,
zu warten sein, wie sich wie sich das verhält, was man aber auch festhalten kann.
Noch bei den Zahlen, hm.
Ist das ja sich die Impfungen auf die ja, wo ja so viel, so viel Hoffnung besteht und dass man sagt, ah, die achtzig plus sind ja jetzt schon so gut wie alle durchgeimpft und,
müsste ja jetzt bald Ruhe herrschen. Hm.
Dem ist nicht ganz so. Wir haben zwar jetzt nicht wie in der zweiten Welle, die die Explosion,
in den achtzig Plus noch einen höheren Altersgrupp, sondern im Gegenteil, die laufen jetzt
gerade äh von der Inzidenz her,
am niedrigsten, also in der in der Altersgruppe achtzig Plus, liegen wir jetzt bei um die sechzig rum in der Institanz und sechzig bis,
neunundsiebzig ähm liegen wir um die achtzig herum während die.
Jüngere.
Bevölkerung, ich sage mal im arbeitsfähigen Alter, also zwischen fünfzehn und vierunddreißig liegt im Moment bundesweit die Institanz bei hundertsiebzig. Ja und.
Bei den ja älteren Berufstätigen fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig liegt sie auch bei gut hundertfünfundvierzig gerade. Tendenz steigend.
Dann kommen.
Als schon die Schulkinder mit einer Institanz von hundertfünfundzwanzig ungefähr und dann die Kinder, die die Kleinkinder mit einer Institanz von hundertzwanzig,
So, das heißt all diese vier Gruppen ähm.
Liegen da doch äh deutlich drüber ähm so über den über der Durchschnitts äh,
Institution oder.
Treiben sie noch nach oben. Ich sage immer, schön die berufstätige Bevölkerung ist, sozusagen das Rückgrat der Pandimie, auf die sich das Virus immer gut verlassen kann, so die die tragen das äh.
Praktisch in jeder Phase der Pandemie bisher äh wurde äh das weitergetragen außer
im ersten Lokdown, da habe ich das jetzt nicht so genau untersucht, aber seitdem den ganzen Sommer über
von denen ging auch dann der Anstieg im Herbst aus von der berufstätigen Bevölkerung,
während ja jetzt die dritte Welle eben äh von Kindern und Jugendlichen hauptsächlich ausging. Aber.
Ja äh wie gesagt, die Berufstätigen immer gut mit dabei und aktuell gerade ja äh oder seit längerem eben bundesweit die fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen, die,
sind das die ja.
Des Virus vermutlich überall hin immer wieder verbreiten und untereinander.
Ja. Hm, zu den zum RW vielleicht.
Noch so zum Verlauf, wie man sich das ungefähr ja sehen kann. Wir hatten als.
Anfang März ist in der ersten Märzhälfte ist der RWT.
Äh von eins oder von knapp über eins, wie wir ihn vorher hatten.
So auf eins Komma eins fünf bis zwei angestiegen, das ging dann bis Ostern so und seit jetzt.
Anfang April ist ja halt in den.
In den Keller gefallen, um auf rund null Komma neun jetzt aktuell.
Hat aber auch wieder jetzt begonnen äh zu steigen. Also der nimmt jetzt auch wieder zu und nimmt jetzt Fahrt auf und.
Wird wahrscheinlich jetzt auch schneller Fahrt aufnehmen.
Also wenn ich das mal alles so ein bisschen zusammennehme, äh man kann sich ja schnell in so einzelne Zahlen auch verlieren. Wir hatten.
Eigentlich im Januar und im Februar noch.
Zahlen und richtig fallende Zahlen. Und das ging alles ganz gut. Dann.
Lockerungsdiskussionen aufgemacht und schon die Ankündigung, das haben wir gesehen im Nachgang haben sofort dieses Geschehen ausgebremst.
Also obwohl dieser Lokdown nicht optimal war. Was aber auch noch mit dazu kam,
B eins eins sieben hat sich genau in dieser Zeit dann halt weiter verbreitet und alle Voraussagen waren wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie was ändern an unseren Lokdow-Zustand, dann wird's halt wieder schlimmer und genau da sind wir jetzt. Das Ganze ist jetzt bis Ostern losgelaufen.
Und während äh Armin Laschet nachgedacht hat.
Haben wir jetzt über Ostern im Prinzip zwei gegenläufige Effekte. Auf der einen Seite, dass diese Osterzeit tatsächlich, dadurch, dass die Schulen zu sind und dass etwas weniger gearbeitet wird, wieder etwas rausgenommen hat.
Und wir kämpfen ja jetzt gegen eine mehr oder weniger.
Vollumfängliche B eins eins sieben, Durchsäuchung. Ich weiß nicht, wo wir jetzt mit den offiziellen Zahlen sind, aber letztes Mal war das ja eigentlich schon so gut wie durch.
Ja, um die also Berlin waren die letzten Zahlen so fünfundachtzig, achtundachtzig Prozent, also wir nähern uns.
Wahrscheinlich jetzt bei den also neunzig Prozent ist so 'ne gute Annahme im Moment B eins eins sieben.
Genau, also im Prinzip des Tickes ist rum, so ähm aber.
Wir können auch den Zahlen weniger trauen aus den genannten Gründen. Und jetzt gibt es schon heute schon erste kleine Anzeichen, dass sich das wieder nach oben entwickelt. Und ich
würde man meinen, wir sind uns eigentlich auch relativ sicher, dass das jetzt der Weg ist, der als nächstes angetreten wird.
Eigentlich recht wenig dagegen getan wird, dass es äh passiert.
Ja um's auch nochmal geguckt, also die Trendwende sagen von ähm hatte.
Anfang Februar stattgefunden so in der ersten Februar äh Woche. So äh bis dahin sankten die Zahlen noch.
Und danach ja ist es gekippt und hat sich dann halt Mitte März oder Anfang März dann beschleunigt äh ja durch sukzessive,
Öffnungen, die stattgefunden haben. Ich habe das mal versucht, so ein bisschen nachzuverfolgen, wann eigentlich was aufgemacht hat. Es hat auch.
Nicht nicht ganz einfach so so rückblickend, weil es gibt kaum so offizielle Historien auch in der Wikipedia wird das nicht mehr nicht mehr nachgehalten,
und ähm,
Ja, dann äh rauszufinden, wann haben denn in Berlin jetzt welche Schulen aufgemacht, weil man denn sucht, dann kriegt man halt of,
Pläne oder Ankündigungen, die dann aber anders gelaufen sind
als es mal angekündigt oder geplant war, sodass ja das nicht ganz einfach ist, aber wie gesagt, man kann festhalten äh wir haben.
Faktisch den Blogdown ähm,
beendet Anfang Februar, wenn man wenn man so will, auch wenn sich das nicht so anfühlt, aber äh ja, Anfang Februar war so der der Punkt, wo dann.
Virus wie er überhand genommen hat.
Okay. Das machen wir jetzt dadraus.
Ja ähm sollten vielleicht noch noch kurz über die Toten sprechen.
Natürlich natürlich auch einen einen Punkt und.
Ja, die Zahlen steigen auch da wieder, jetzt seit zwei Tagen haben wir.
Vermehrte äh wieder steigende Zahlen bei den Toten.
Was eigentlich nicht sein sollte oder,
zumindest äh in der Vorstellungswelt der Leute, die meinen mit den Impfungen würde jetzt
alles gut und tut und wir bräuchten nichts mehr zu tun so. Ganz offensichtlich ist dem nicht so und wir haben eben.
Leider auch Anstieg äh bei den allerältesten beziehungsweise bis vor zwei Wochen,
noch belag dort auch der, sage ich mal, RWT in der Altersgruppe.
Was eigentlich so ein bisschen eine Krücke ist äh so eigentlich gibt's in dem Sinne einen R-Wert in der Altersgruppe nicht, das ist eher so eine mathematische Konstruktion, aber nichtsdestotrotz zeigt es halt ganz gut,
ob sich jetzt innerhalb einer bestimmten Altersgruppe die Infektion jetzt ausbreitet und zurückgeht und zeigt es in der Wertescala
vergleichbar mit,
normalen R-Wert, den wir kennen, aber man kann ja nicht sagen, jetzt neun alte stecken halt jetzt zehn alte, sondern das geht natürlich dann über die Altersgruppen, deswegen.
Ist das mit dem R Wert gesagt eher so ein bisschen theoretisch, aber nichtsdestotrotz kann man feststellen, dass.
Ja, sich bis vor zwei Wochen bei bei achtzig plus die Infektion ausgebreitet.
Ja wieder als die Zahlen hochgegangen sind. Das heißt halt ganz klar die Impfquote.
Bei den über Achtzigjährigen ist noch immer nicht so.
Dass sie in dieser Altersgruppe für einen nachhaltigen Rückgang der Infektionszahlen sorgen würde. Ja.
Und das ist auch das ist auch durchaus konsistent mit der Theorie. Hm.
Dass im Grunde genommen so dreißig Prozent ungeimpfte äh für das Virus ausreichen, um wenn ich zusätzliche Schutzmaßnahmen getroffen werden, sich ausbreiten zu können, ja? Das heißt.
Unter siebzig Prozent Impfquote bei den Alten und es kann sogar noch ein bisschen höher liegen sind die weiterhin gefährdet.
In größere, in größerer Anzahl zu versterben.
Mit anderen Worten wir tun noch nicht mal genug, um um diese Zahlen wieder zurück äh zu.
Also es wird sich jetzt nach Ostern zeigen, wie dort der Trend aussieht. Jetzt die haben die Impfungen ja angezogen, aber der theoriet ja,
dürften wir bei den meisten Altersgruppen.
Impfquoten von zehn, zwanzig oder dreißig Prozent, die bewirken einfach.
Überhaupt nicht genug, so da kann man, also das kann man fast ignorieren, nicht ganz, aber sagen dreißig Prozent durchgeimpft, macht halt jetzt äh keinen großen Unterschied und ähm.
Deswegen eigentlich nur in der Altersgruppe achtzig plus so, wenn's dann so auf sechzig, siebzig, achtzig Prozent hochgeht, sollte man.
Effekte sehen, aber vorher sind die einfach gering im Vergleich jetzt zu anderen Effekten, also Logdown oder nicht Lokdown, macht halt äh viel größeren Unterschied als jetzt äh.
Dreißig oder vierzig Prozent geimpft wo Unversus gar nicht geimpft.
Oder auch sechzig Prozent geimpft. So, also man, das haben wir auch immer gesagt, das dauert halt länger
das wirkt sich eben nicht so digital aus nach dem Motto okay, jetzt hier Knopf, alle durchgeimpft,
und jetzt ist Schluss mit mit wie es so so geht, so läuft das halt plus, dass du halt immer auch noch einen gewissen Anteil von Leuten hast.
Denen die Impfung einfach nicht funktioniert. Das ist halt auch normal, so im Versager, Leute mit geschwächten Immunsystemen und und kenne da jetzt die Quoten nicht.
Aber üblicherweise ja äh bei anderen Impfstoffen hat man so fünf, zehn, zwanzig Prozent manchmal im Versager.
Das scheint bei den.
Impfstoffen deutlich geringer zu sein, aber nichtsdestotrotz muss man davon ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich.
Eier von zehn Personen, die Impfung nicht so anschlägt, wie man sich das erhofft oder erwarte.
Und etwa die Übertragung verhindert, sondern einen Teil der geimpften äh kommt,
auch weiterhin als Überträger äh in in Frage und man kann sich auch bei einem der geimpft ist, anstecken, hängt natürlich auch noch wiederum davon ab
wann jemand geimpft wurde und ob erste oder zweite Dosis, aber was so die Politik,
offenbar verstanden hat oder oder gerne hört. Ist
dass äh ja mit den Impfungen schlagartig
alles gut wird und dass die Geimpften dann alle Freiheiten zurückkriegen können und keine Masken mehr tragen müssen. Konflikt gab's halt auch schon in den im amerikanischen Senat vor Wochen. Der kommt jetzt bei uns auch,
auf die Frage, wozu soll denn äh so ein grüner Impfpass jetzt eigentlich berechtigen? Und meiner Meinung nach.
Ist das einzig gerechtfertigte, wozu so einen so eine Impfung berechtigen könnte oder sollte es in ein anderes Land zu fahren, weil man dann dort wahrscheinlich,
dem ähm Gesundheitssystem im Zweifelsfall nicht äh äh zur Last fällt, wenn man sich infiziert.
Ja das halte ich für gerechtfertigt, alles andere, also Befreiung von Masken oder anderen Dingen.
Einzige Ausnahme.
Sagen, sind jetzt die Testpflichten, die jetzt hochkommen, ähm.
Ja, das hatten wir äh schon und je je mehr Daten ich im Moment.
Bekomme äh umso skeptischer äh werde ich den Tests gegenüber, ob das tatsächlich überhaupt,
Sinn macht mit den Selbsttests oder mit den mit den Schnelltests, außer in ganz, ganz wenigen spezifischen Situationen, aber Erped so viele Fälle gehört.
Wo Leute äh sich komplett schnell getestet haben und hinterher dann die Hälfte infiziert war. Ja, also kann ich mittlerweile reichen da meine Finger nicht mehr aus, um die Berichte äh.
Äh ja zu zählen und natürlich ist das auch eher anekdotisch und und keine Datenbasis, aber bei einem Blick auf die Daten und da gab's ja jetzt diesen Brief,
vom äh RKI, der nicht veröffentlicht werden.
Sollte gesagt, das ist das war jetzt nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt, sondern da hat halt die Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz, hat halt dann
dass Robert Koch Institut
Gebieten bis zur nächsten MPK Sitzung doch ein Bericht darüber vorzulegen ob beziehungsweise ab welchem Zeitpunkt geimpfte Person mit hinreichender Sicherheit nicht infektiös sind, dass eine Einbeziehung
Testkonzepte möglicherweise absolut wird. So und.
Mein Gefühl äh also sie hat beziehen sich dann oft auch auf diesen Cockrain.
Review, den wir ja auch schon mal vor einem Monat glaube ich.
Ich glaube, letzte Woche hatten wir den sogar nochmal.
Ja äh.
So und da den interpretieren sie so, dass.
Bei Personen mit Symptomen zweiundsiebzig Prozent der äh infizierten.
Rausgefischt werden bei.
Äh symptomatisch infizierten nur achtundfünfzig Prozent.
Das sind natürlich, wenn man sich dann vor zwei Sendungen unsere Rechen äh äh Beispiele nochmal anhört mit,
ja, wie das so ist mit der Empfindlichkeit und der Genauigkeit von Tests kann man sagen, bei den Zahlen, ja, wenn das die sagen, das ist, was in der Praxis passiert und,
da muss man im Moment von ausgehen ja kann man auch würfeln.
So, ne, kann man das auch auch auswürfeln, also ich glaube ähm das mit den Tests hm.
Weil ich bin da auch jetzt viel privat gefragt worden, so wie sieht's denn aus? Soll ich denn jetzt irgendwie hier Test machen oder wie ist denn das mit dem mit dem Freitesten und.
Wir hatten gesagt oder Experten sagen, okay, so ein so ein Testergebnis gilt halt für zwölf Stunden.
Ungefähr, wenn's denen dann tatsächlich richtig ist, also bei ist, ja, bei den bei achtundfünfzig Prozent.
So oder bei bei ja dann über vierzig Prozent.
Wird, wird da nichts angezeigt, so vierzig Prozent rutschen halt eh durch, aber das Problem ist eben.
Dass du dich einen Tag vorher oder eine Stunde vorher angesteckt haben kannst oder zwei Tage vorher und du machst jetzt den Test und der ist negativ.
Und bei ungeschickten Timing,
würde er eine Stunde später positiv ausfallen, weil du schon eigentlich dabei bist, jetzt Virus zu produzieren und die Konzentration steigt und das dann im Prinzip eigentlich nach einem paar Stund.
Oder je länger oder so, je länger die Zeit nach dem Testergebnis umso noch weniger aussagekräftig ist. So, das heißt.
Wenn man jetzt wirklich für Sicherheit sorgen wollte und Tests eben.
Entsprechend einsetzt, dann muss man halt eine Gruppe von Personen durchtesten. Da müssen sich alle in Quarantäne begeben,
äh dann muss man sie nochmal durchtesten und dann
ähm können sie halt einigermaßen sicher Zeit miteinander verbringen. In dem Moment, wo dann aber jemand auch nur
in den nächsten Späti äh geht um Zigaretten zu holen oder keine Ahnung oder sonst die sich mit jemandem außerhalb der Gruppe trifft ist das ganze Konzept,
äh schon wieder ja ähm durch durchbrochen. So, dann ähm ja ähm.
Also mit anderen Worten für.
So die die normale Anwendung oder so wie das bisher jetzt geplant ist auch in Schulen oder um in Geschäfte zu gehen und so sind,
Auswirkungen, also sie halbieren vielleicht das das Risiko äh,
es zu einer Infektion kommt. Also haben, wenn man jetzt in Korona Schutzfaktor denkt, vielleicht einen Corona-Schutzfaktor von zwei oder drei während
Maske aufsetzt, hast du halt gleich zwanzig bis dreißig ohne großen Hessel in beide Richtungen, ja.
Mein, der Test schützt sich auch nicht davor, dich selber anzustecken, ne, was sehr viel interessanter wäre äh zu.
Ja gut, man muss dazu sagen, an den Schulen sollen natürlich auch nach wie vor Masken getragen werden, ne? Also die Tests äh heißen ja jetzt nicht, dass alle dann wieder rumrennen, als wäre nichts gewesen. Von daher gibt's schon noch verschiedene äh Kaskaden. Der Abwehr.
Aber im Zweifelsfall führen sie eher fast noch zu einer falschen Sicherheit nach dem Motto, oh wir haben sind ja alle getestet äh und äh führen.
Aus meiner Sicht sehr wahrscheinlich dazu, dass äh dann die Maskendisziplin nachlässt oder überhaupt die Disziplin äh äh nachlässt, weil man der Meinung ist.
Ich bin gesund, ich bin getestet, was soll das. Ja, so ich glaube, der ist der Effek
am Ende wahrscheinlich überwiegt oder zumindest den den kleinen Effek,
diese Testzeit sehr wohl infizierte eben rausziehen und verhindern, dass die äh sie zumindest aus den Übertragungsketten rausnehmen, dass dieser Effekt vermutlich äh komplett äh aufgewogen
Wogen oder aufgehoben äh äh wird durch den Effekt, dass die Leute unvorsichtiger werden, wenn sie die Tests machen. Aber das ist jetzt da habe ich jetzt keine keine Zahlen, das ist jetzt eher so ähm Einschätzung.
Menschlicher Psyche. Und mir wird's glaube ich auch so gehen. Weiß nicht, wie wie du es siehst, äh ob du dich mein,
Wir wissen zwar, auf der einen Seite, dass.
Man sich nicht allzu viel sicherer fühlen äh kann, aber man kann sich ja solchen Effekten ja nicht komplett verschließen. Das hat man ja nicht nicht völlig unter Kontrolle.
Ja, es ist ähm
ist einfach zunehmend schwierig. Ich meine jetzt gerade so mit der äh neuen Virusvariante bin ich halt tendenziell eher noch vorsichtiger geworden. Befinde mich jetzt irgendwie de facto seit Oktober Ende Oktober so richtig im Logdown, also es,
diese Straße, in der ich wohne irgendwie kaum verlassen, wenn man jetzt mal die Spaziergänge, die hier so ab und zu mal durch den.
Ähm durch die Umgebung mache, mal davon rausnimmt. Also nirgendswo hin. Und ich werde jetzt auch die Kinder nicht mehr in die Schule schicken.
Es hat jetzt einfach überhaupt gar keinen ähm also das Risiko will ich jetzt einfach überhaupt nicht eingehen, weil ich sehe nicht ein warum. Ist jetzt ähm Zeugnisse ist eh durch.
Nach einem Jahr irgendwie Vorsicht und Rücksicht äh so wäre das,
echt ätzendes Test. Das kam mir auch noch äh jetzt auf auf der letzten Strecke irgendwie dann noch krank zu werden und ähm so von denen.
Leuten, ich kenne jetzt nicht so viele, die die Krankheit durchgemacht haben, mit denen ich.
Die meisten haben das zum Glück
geschafft, äh, das bisher zu verhindern oder zu vermeiden, aber da wo ich's gehört hab
das äh selbst selbst bei Leuten, die eigentlich gesund sind und normalerweise ja gar nicht so Risikogruppe oder so gehören, was die erzählt haben.
Ja, das das will man nicht haben. Ich weiß nicht, hast du da irgendwie äh von jemandem gehört oder aus erster Hand berichte von Leuten.
Also die Hauptreaktion war, dass alle da getrost drauf hätten, verzichten könnten. Das ist einfach mal jetzt rein, so als Erkrankung während des Krankheitszustands einfach nicht lustig.
Und da gab's natürlich alle möglichen Schweren, also es gab Leute, die einfach nur so Milz äh zwei Wochen vor sich hingehustet haben. Gab aber auch Leute, die einfach tagelang mit schwersten Kopfschmerzen unterwegs waren und was weiß ich nicht noch für Nebenwirkungen. Also das ist wie
nichts was man haben will und ich kann mich irgendwie selber auch nicht äh erinnern, dass ich in den letzten Jahren überhaupt mal nennenswert über einen längeren Zeitraum,
krank war, wo ich wirklich so sagen würde, hier habe ich jetzt gelitten, deswegen brauche ich das jetzt auch gerade mal nicht.
Aber was halt sehr viel beunruhigender ist, ist halt so dieses dieser Risikofaktor wird so. Das finde ich halt einmal abgesehen jetzt vom Todesrisiko,
zugegebenermaßen jetzt vielleicht in meinem Alter nicht so megawahrscheinlich ist, aber auch nicht ausgeschlossen ist,
aber ist halt äh es gibt einen zunehmenden Maß. Ich habe jetzt leider für die Sendung hier nichts vorbereitet, weil es ein bisschen unübersichtlich ist, auch dieses Feld, aber es gibt sehr viele Studien jetzt, die äh diesen Longkowits äh Aspekt.
Betrachten und teilweise halt auch bei Kindern.
Jetzt mit der neuen Virusvariante äh bei den wirklich äh Erkrankten dann irgendwie so sieben von jeder siebte, der dann auch wirklich langfristig ähm Folgen davon spürt.
Also bei den Engländern äh kann man äh die machen da ganz gute Studien oder haben da wie immer ganz gute Daten äh
so bei uns gibt's da auch Erhebungen, aber nicht so regelmäßig und nicht
in dem in dem Umfang aber was man dort bei den Engländern nachgucken kann ist.
Nach Symptomen aufgeschlüsselt, wie viel Prozent der Leute nach wie viel Wochen noch welche Symptome verspürten und.
Äh der sagen der eine Fall, das war der der erste Infizierte, den ich persönlich.
Kenne, der sich während der ersten Welle infiziert hat, äh der meint halt
es hätte halt fünf Wochen gedauert, bis irgendwie Geruch und Geschmack langsam wieder zurückgekommen sind und das war bei ihm deswegen besonderes Problem, weil er
ohnehin Probleme hat irgendwie genügend Gewicht zu halten und äh hat dann eben in dieser
In dieser Phase der Appetitlosigkeit dann eben nochmal äh weiter deutlich äh ja an an Körpergewicht verloren, was halt ja.
Dann dann auch nicht nicht schön ist und ja ähm und,
sag mal fünf fünf Wochen oder so nicht in Restaurants äh äh gehen zu können ist ja eine Sache, aber fünf Wochen lang äh überhaupt beim Essen
sagen nichts zu schmecken alleine ist
äh schon keine Erfahrung, die man machen möchte, aber das ist wahrscheinlich dann noch eher die harmloseste, wobei man sagen muss.
Dass das natürlich die dieses Symptom eins ist, äh bei dem Nervenzellen geschädigt werden, ja? Also.
Sind halt Nervenzellen angegriffen und das kann nicht gut sein, ja? Das kann natürlich dann nicht nur Geruch und Geschmack, sondern eben auch äh ja andere.
Probleme, die eben mit der Weiterleitung von Nervensignalen zusammenhängen.
Plus ja tausend, wie gesagt, tausend andere Symptome, also es das Unschöne an diesem Virus, auch im Gegensatz zum Grippevirus,
dass Krankheitsbild ist halt ein ganz anderes Während Grippe üblicherweise hm ja.
Normalerweise eben nicht den ganzen Körper und nicht so viele Organe direkt äh angreift, passiert das halt bei Kowit eben schon, dass das geht halt äh ja in,
Zellen und Bereiche rein äh praktisch praktisch überall. Ja ähm also.
Von nicht nur von den Lungen, nicht nur Lunge und und und Atemwege, sondern.
Ja Nieren, Leber, äh Extremus,
Risiko bei Leuten, die halt irgendwie eingeschränkte Funktion der Liebe haben, dass das äh extrem hohen Risikofaktoren.
Und also ja, man man möchte es einfach nicht haben.
Gehen wir nochmal lieber noch ein bisschen mehr auf paar ähm positive Zahlen ein, die gab's diese Woche auch.
Das Impf der Sport berichtet, dass tatsächlich mit Beginn dieser Woche die Impfzahlen in Deutschland dann doch das erste Mal wirklich nennenswert spürbar nach oben gegangen sind.
Wir hatten also jetzt noch das Osterwochenende, das heißt auch am Montag waren so die Impfzahlen äh gering, wobei sie schon Ostermontag so auf einem,
höheren Niveau im Vergleich zu den letzten,
Wochen gewesen ist, also bei knapp zweihundertfünfzigtausend, aber jetzt eben auch nichts, was einen groß äh aus dem Bett wirft
Dienstag sprang's dann langsam an, dreihundertzweiundsiebzigtausend. Am Mittwoch waren's dann schon sechshundertachtundsechzigtausend und am Donnerstag
über siebenhunderttausend knapp siebenhundertzwanzigtausend Geimpfte.
Warum? Na ja gut äh lässt sich eigentlich relativ leicht erklären. Auf der einen Seite gab es deutlich höhere Impflieferungen, also Impfstofflieferungen. Es wurden im Vergleich zur,
Woche davor, mal locker vier Millionen äh Impfstoffdosenmeer geliefert und.
Das äh hat natürlich dann auch dazu geführt, dass eben mehr verimpft werden konnte und es wurden halt jetzt auch die Hausärzte mit eingebunden, so dass dann eben diese Zahlen auch wirklich die Arme erreichen kann.
Wird sich jetzt zeigen, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Also wenn man jetzt wirklich so ein Niveau von von sechshunderttausend pro Tag äh erreichen.
Das wäre sicherlich nicht nicht schlecht, ja? Also das, sehr viel mehr wird's jetzt nicht sein, also wir haben jetzt vier Millionen Impfstoffe geliefert, wenn man das jetzt mal äh teilt eben durch.
Die sieben Tage, dann können wir halt so im Schnitt auf fünfhundertsiebzigtausend kommen. Sprich.
Wenn dann stark ein Wochenend klingt natürlich wieder sehen und irgendwo so bei fünfhunderttausend, denke ich mal, ist so unser Mittel. Ja und dann muss natürlich die Impfstofflieferung auch weiterhin so zuverlässig kommen.
Das wird sich zeigen. Hm, ich werde es hier mal äh aus den Grafiken locker interpretiere
jetzt zwar schon nochmal so ein gewisser Schub von
Björn Tech dabei, aber tatsächlich war es vor allem Astra Senika, was jetzt ähm einen großen Zuwachs gehabt hat und ähm stimmt nicht ganz moderner, auch nochmal fuffzig Prozent mehr, aber das sind eh relativ wenige.
Es ist jetzt in der nächsten ähm Woche damit zu rechnen, dass doch der Anteil von Bayerntech sehr viel größer werden wird, weil halt jetzt eigentlich langsam der Output von dem.
Ähm Werk in Marburg ankommen muss.
Von daher würde ich mal meinen, wenn's richtig, richtig gut läuft, sehen wir dann nächste Woche vielleicht auch schon so Impfzahlen in der Größenordnung von einer Million pro Tag,
nicht im Schnitt über die Woche, aber solche Zahlen halte ich jetzt zumindest für möglich.
Und die brauchen wir auch, weil sonst dauert das einfach alles äh viel zu lang, ja? Also das klingt jetzt erstmal alles ganz toll, aber das das wäre halt schon früher äh ganz gut gewesen, wenn man halt in irgendeiner Form bei der Bekämpfung der Pandemie
hier vorankommen will, dann kann man natürlich nur hoffen, dass die Leute auch da.
Mitmachen, also dass die Impfbereitschaft auch irgendwie funktioniert.
Okay, gut, ähm, so vielleicht zu den Zahlen insgesamt. Jetzt wolltest du vorhin, glaube ich, sowieso nochmal auf diese, eine Empfehlung vom RKI hinaus und vielleicht hat man ja
grundsätzlich jetzt nochmal auch schauen, was ich eigentlich jetzt so im in der ganzen politischen Landschaft.
Bewegt beziehungsweise sich nicht bewegt, kann man glaube ich eher sagen, weil so also man ist ja schon wirklich einiges gewohnt, hab's eingangs schon gesagt, aber man ist auch irgendwo total erstaunt.
Wie, wie wenig eigentlich passiert. Also ich glaube vor zwei Wochen hat dann Angela Merkel angekündigt, sie schaut sich das jetzt keine vierzehn Tage mehr an.
War jetzt vor vor zwölf Tagen.
Was jetzt an diesem Wochenende noch für kolossale Ergebnisse kommen werden. Wahrscheinlich nicht so viel und für Montag war eigentlich auch mal wieder eine so eine Quatschrunde.
Gedacht und die ist jetzt auch schon abgesagt worden.
Ja ähm gut, wir hatten's ja nicht anders,
erwartet äh so, dass äh dass das jetzt schnell gehen wird, äh obwohl die Kanzlerin,
glaube ich schon ganz gerne hätte, wenn das schneller gehen würde und sie ja im Hintergrund auch dabei ist, Druck zu machen und.
Es hat sich ja auch etwas in Bewegung gesetzt, also jetzt zumindest halt erfolgreich eine Diskussion in Gang gesetzt
und 'ne ganze Reihe von Leuten auch auf ihre Seite gezogen und es läuft halt jetzt nach wie vor die Debatte darum und,
ob eben des Infektionsschutzgesetz dem Bund mehr Kompetenzen geben soll,
Ländern vorzuschreiben, welche Maßnahmen sie zu treffen haben,
und welche nicht und diese Debatte tobt halt jetzt und da können wir jetzt sehen, wie sich halt gestandene Ministerpräsidenten,
aufführen, wie kleine Kinder, ja, trotzig ähm.
Erst hatten wir das ganze Jahr mit Armin Laschet, der dann sagte soll ich denn auch noch machen? Äh irgendwie, ich habe alles getan,
so mehr Maßnahmen gibt's nicht, ja und äh ja ähm lasst mich in Ruhe, also.
Übernehme keine Verantwortung, ja? So Investor Trump Manier so.
Was habe ich mit Kurve zu tun? Habe ich, habe ich das erfunden irgendwie? Habe ich das hier verbreitet oder was äh so, was habe ich damit zu tun so ungefähr, ja,
hatte man das das Gefühl, dann hat er sich ja überlegt über Ostern nochmal nachzudenken das war auch ganz ich mein gut,
es ist also es ist nie zu spät.
Seine Meinung zu ändern, so, das ist immer.
Kann man, kann man machen und das das ist auch in der Pandimie auch auch jetzt noch nützlich, ja? Ich meine, wäre halt nützlicher gewesen, das im.
Oktober.
Schon mal oder vor Oktober mal nachgedacht zu haben und dann zu vermeiden, dass irgendwie fünfzigtausend Leute sterben und zwei Millionen infiziert werden,
So, das war teuer, das war richtig teuer.
Sache und schmerzhaft so für für viele und ja aber das heißt jetzt nicht
das ist, dass wir das erstens nicht noch toppen können mit der dritten Welle, dass sie nicht noch schlimmer werden kann als die zweite, also wir können, man kann's durchaus noch mehr verkacken
und ja darum geht's jetzt gerade und.
Man äh und jetzt äh hat sich halt Stefan Weil, Herr Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen zu Wort gemeldet SPD und der.
Meinte jetzt wird nicht nur zitiert, sondern hat selber sich selbst zitiert in einem kurzen von Tweets und hat sich kann man sich halt auch äh so im Morgenmagazin.
Anschauen, so was er da gesagt hat, aber selbst zitiert er sich mit diejenigen, die einen kurzen und harten Lokdown fordern, sind bisher viele Antworten schuldig geblieben. Was heißt kurz.
Eine Woche, drei Wochen, was heißt hart? Soll die gesamte Wirtschaft stillgelegt und Schulen und Kitas komplett geschlossen werden? Ähm.
Daraufhin Pavel Bayer, ja.
Ja genau also ich mein ich wollte zuerst wie,
ausführliche Antworten, aber ähm,
Ich denke mit diesen ein, mit diesen zwei Buchstaben ist dann halt auch schon schon vieles gesagt und natürlich könnte man jetzt ausführlicher sagen, äh so kurz heißt,
solange wie es dauert halt und man da ist
irgendwas waren sagen, da ist ja Niedersachsen dann auch in einer super Situation mit einer relativ niedrigen Institz und so und wenn Nines jetzt.
Ja konsequent durchziehen würden, könnte Niedersachsen eines der ersten Länder sein, äh was ja einstellige Institzen,
erreicht. Also ich verstehe gar nicht warum äh oder sagen wir mal so.
Ich verstehe äh dass er sich äh so als Ministerpräsident eines der.
Anführungszeichen niedrig Institzländer, wobei die Institanz dort auch immer noch höher ist als auf dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle oder vergleichbar.
Ist äh zumindest so, es ist jetzt alles andere als als entspannt dort. Die die Situation.
Aber die Denke ist da halt eine eine ganz ganz andere.
Und äh nehme also auch das ist jetzt ähm.
Diese Kowit Verharmlosung oder dieses.
Diese Unfähigkeit, Epidemie zu verstehen und dieses.
Meinen mit dem Virus verhandeln zu können und Dinge nicht nicht wahrhaben zu wollen. So.
Das.
Ist ähm ja, das ist irgendwie symptomatisch für äh Politiker unterschiedlichster,
Parteien. So, aber es gibt eine gewisse Häufung, äh aber am Ende des Tages äh wird man, wird es,
wirklich nicht einfach werden irgendwie sagen dann 'ne Auswahl zu treffen
welche Partei sich denn jetzt als Ganzes dort noch am vernünftigsten Verhalten hat, weil Idioten äh scheint's überall äh zu geben, auch bei der SPD.
Also ich sehe überhaupt gar keine Partei, die sich jetzt hier besonders äh mit Ruhm bekleckert
um ehrlich zu sein. Also wer auch immer in irgendeiner Regierungsverantwortung ist, egal ob das jetzt die die Grünen in Baden-Württemberg sind oder wie die SPD oder die CDU oder auch die Linke damit Ramelow, alle sind so ein bisschen.
Also vor allem, was ich halt überhaupt nicht verstehe ist, dass sie sich sehr viel mehr als so der Verteidiger ihrer individuellen in Anführungsstrichen Freiheit sehen in diesem, in dieser ganzen Kaskade und immer so ähm.
Land vor den Regelungen des Bundes verteidigen müssen. Das scheint mir so ein bisschen so ihre primäre Aufgabe zu sein. Also sie sehen sich mehr da drin äh in der Rolle jetzt.
Noch besser davon zu kommen, was auch wie man auch ähm immer das jetzt definiert im Bezug auf neue Regelung. Ja, anstatt daran wirklich mitzuarbeiten.
Leute, wir haben's jetzt hier schon tausendmal gesagt und wieder wir wiederholen uns einfach äh die ganze Zeit. Also es ist.
Jetzt sind wir genau in der Situation, in der wir nie sein wollten, so. Alles, was wir gerade diskutieren, wäre sowas von vermeidbar gewesen, wenn man einfach gesagt hätte, im November,
Lokdown und zwar richtig und zwar genauso wie im März oder am besten noch ein bisschen härter.
Knalle, dicke, fette Null, so. Ich verstehe auch, dass es Probleme gibt mit so bestimmten Industriebereichen.
Ja, das ist durch, also es gibt so es gibt so Industrien die.
Die sich schwer herunterfahren lassen und vor allem, die sich danach sehr schwer wieder hochfahren lassen und wo äh extreme.
Auswirkungen sind so ein bisschen so ist Kanalmäßig, ne, bis das alles dann wieder äh nach so einer Sperrung alles wieder so in in die richtige Reihenfolge kommt. Das hat eine ganze Menge an an Folgekosten.
Und das sind auch so Industrien, die
die so sagen wir mal für Deutschland weltweit 'ne extreme Bedeutung haben. Die die es nicht nur der individuelle finanzielle Ausfall einer bestimmten Zahl ist sondern wo man dann in gewisser Hinsicht auch irgendwelche Wettläufe langfristig verlieren kann,
Egal, aber es ändert einfach nichts an der Tatsache, dass so wie es dann stattdessen,
gelaufen ist, dass man nämlich im Wesentlichen eigentlich gar nichts getan hat, sich die ganze Zeit erst immer äh schön geredet hat. Und als es dann,
einmal dann auch wirklich endlich mal im Januar
und im Februar so ein bisschen auf die Siegerstraße hinaus liefern und wirklich dachte so, okay äh das war jetzt zwar hart und doof und alles und so weiter, aber zumindest gehen die Zahlen runter. Dann
irgendwie vorzeitig wieder äh auf einen harten Kehr zu machen und auch überhaupt nicht.
Bezug zu haben zu diesen ganzen Zahlen. Ne, also erst war was haben sie alle geschrien als Berlin dann mal eine Institanz von fünfzig hatte,
Ja, Sodom und Gomorra, da war das irgendwie die Zombie-Hauptstadt der Welt. Oh Gott und der ist ja aus Berlin. Komm mit, können wir den jetzt hier überhaupt über die Landesgrenze lassen? Und jetzt so, naja, fünfunddreißig, hundert, irgendwie zweihundert ist ja jetzt auch nicht so schlimm und und überhaupt diese Zahlen, was soll denn das überhaupt äh
gehen wir aus der Sonne. Das das ist irgendwie so diese Mentalität. Also man merkt einfach, dass da überhaupt nichts verstanden wurde und das das kann einen natürlich schon ähm.
Verärgern, vor allem weil man sich jetzt auf einmal in dieser bekloppten Situation befindet, dass man,
Das Regierungshandeln einfach kritisieren muss.
Ja und und schon fast aufpassen muss nicht mit diesen ganzen Schreihals äh da Unisono ein Lied zu singen die die das zwar auch schon die ganze Zeit tun nur eben aus vollkommen anderen Motiven und Gründen heraus.
Ja? Also vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz und konkret nochmal zu zu Stefan Beil, er hat mir gesagt, abgesehen davon, dass irgendwie ja oh Gott, sollen wir jetzt alles zumachen und wie lange und überhaupt und dann
ja.
Das ist also so ein halbes die Railing äh äh der erste der erste Tweet so nach dem Motto Plus Framing, eine Woche, drei Wochen.
Ja das ist sozusagen setzt er dann schon mal, ja, also mehr als drei Wochen geht aber gar nicht, schon mal, also wenn höchstens eine Woche, aber also äh,
So, aber dann,
Meine ist jetzt nicht dumm, er weiß auch, dass es den Ostereffekt äh gibt, aber stellt sich dann auf den äh äh Standpunkt auch noch, dass äh in Niedersachsen die vereinbarte Notbremse korrekt,
umgesetzt wird und zeigt dann mit den Fingern auf andere Länder erstmal äh,
die doch erstmal die schärfere Maßnahmen fordern, die bisherigen doch bitte erstmal umsetzen äh äh sollen und äh sage dann auch noch, ja und die Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben ihr,
Verhalten offensichtlich die Ernst der Lage angepasst und können von der Politik zu Recht erwarten, dass jetzt nicht erneut in hektischen Aktionismus verfällt, sondern verlässlich, konsequent,
umsichtig handeln? Ja.
Super. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal jetzt kommen wir mal vielleicht noch mit ein paar Zahlen und und Fakten ähm,
Ja, wie gesagt, Niedersachsen hat jetzt,
traditionell auch am unteren Rand des Spektrums was so die deutschen Bundesländer angeht und die Institenzen ein bemerkenswertes Ding ist aber.
Wenn man sich den Instituzverlauf in Niedersachsen anguckt, den hatten die in der.
Zweiten Welle so drei Pieks, die ungefähr gleich hoch waren, so bei hundertfünfundzwanzig und haben's jetzt geschafft in der dritten Welle äh.
Of
Anfang April auch auf dieselbe Höhe zu kommen. Das heißt, in Niedersachsen war jetzt im April die Instit äh schon
so hoch oder ein Ticken höher sogar als in der zweiten Welle. Das ist ungewöhnlich
weil wieder bundesweit noch in anderen Bundesländern ist es so, das heißt da könnte quasi auch so ein gewisser Nachhol,
Effekt da sein und wenn man sich dann.
Auch noch angucke, was denn so in Niedersachsen passiert ist, dann,
sieht man da auch ganz klar die fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen und die.
Ja etwas etwas älteren, aber vor allen Dingen die die jüngere.
Werktätige Bevölkerung, äh die ist extrem äh dominant und die war in Niedersachsen auch nicht sagen Haupttreiber, also da heißt es, wo es in Niedersachsen.
So richtig losging und bevor es dann,
achtzig plus erfasst hat, so im im November man kann man sagen, waren's ähm ja die Berufstätigen,
so VW, keine Ahnung, ob's jetzt wirklich VW war, aber gibt ja so viel auch nicht in Niedersachsen irgendwie, ne? Es gibt ja keine richtigen Städte oder so, nur so kleinere äh,
wie Hannover, also.
Äh und äh ja ist das eben in Hannover ist das nicht so ein größerer Berliner Bezirk ungefähr, was so wie ein Einwohnern.
Fünfhunderttausend.
Okay, dann anderthalb Bezirke.
Ja, ja. Ist schon eine Großstadt eine ordentliche.
Ja also äh wie gesagt, das sieht man, also in Niedersachsen äh sieht man das ein bisschen ausgeprägter als.
In vielen anderen Bundesländern, wobei der Trend generell ist, aber ja, es ist die die berufstätige Bevölkerung, die dort die dritte Welle äh die zweite Welle losgetreten hat und auch sagen Hauptmotor der.
Dritten Welle jetzt ist, wobei sich in der dritten Welle eben auch Schulen und Kitas mit
eingereiht
haben und äh eben auch dieser Effekt ja, dass äh die dann speziell die Kitas, die haben dann die Berufstätigen fast eingeholt und waren dann tatsächlich
zweithöchste Institz mit hundertachtzig ungefähr, ja, hundertachtzig, hundertneunzig jetzt auf dem,
äh bisherigen Höhepunkt der der dritten Welle,
Ja und ähm gut ansonsten ist aber generell, muss man sagen, ist Niedersachsen bisher relativ glimpflich.
Davon gekommen, was die Gesamtzahl der Infizierten angeht, es ist so ja, am zweitwenigsten.
Betroffen von von allen Ländern hm ja.
Nach äh also Schleswig-Holstein ist da aber besser. Und.
Auch bei den Todesfällen hatte man relativ viel Glück, da sieht's halt genauso aus so, von daher ja.
Kann ich ein kleines Stück weit nachvollziehen, wenn weil sagt äh zu erstmal mit dem Finger auf andere Länder zeigt
auf der anderen Seite gibt es da nichts, worauf er stolz sein könnte, ha? Ähm,
das ist also auch die Zahlen in Niedersachsen sind nicht gut und sind sind zu hoch. Und dann.
Haben mich jetzt einfach mal zu dem zu dem.
Problem äh Kommunikation von Wissenschaft mit Politik oder Politik.
Der Wissenschaft, so das scheint mir.
Auch extrem schwierig zu sein, weil Wissenschaftler es gewohnt sind normalerweise sich anders auszudrücken, sich.
Nicht immer unbedingt jetzt politisch auszudrücken, sondern halt.
Na ja, zu versuchen, irgendwie die Welt so zu beschreiben, wie sie ist mit eben bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeiten und Risiken und eben nicht mit absoluten Aussagen.
Die Politik hält das aber oder viele Politiker, wenn die dann sowas lesen, halten das aber für Füllworte, die sie einfach,
beim Lesen wahrscheinlich einfach überspringen so, sondern sie greifen sich dann irgendwie
zu die Kernaussage raus, die wird dann überhöht und verkürzt und dann,
sagen ja äh in die in die Welt äh hinaus gebracht und das.
Weim, so ein, so ein Punkt, was mir dann aufgestoßen ist, das äh ja.
Ehemalige Kollegin im Abgeordnetenhaus Ramona Popp jetzt Wirtschaftssenatorin in Berlin hat.
Halt oder wurde in der in der Berliner Zeitung zitiert mit.
Nachdem das RKI bestätigt hat, dass Geimpfte nicht mehr das Virus verbreiten, muss der Impfpass auf der nächsten MBK Thema sein. Wir brauchen eine bundesweite, am besten EU-weite Lösung. So. Ich habe mich dann gefrag.
OK, hat es RKI jetzt wirklich bestätigt, das geimpfte nicht mehr des Virus verbrei.
Auch nicht dran erinnern.
Würde mich doch äh sehr wundern und da kommt eben dann sagt jener ähm ähm Brief äh.
Der da nicht an die Öffentlichkeit sollte beziehungsweise das ist das wahrscheinlich wo sie ihre eben Information hatte und was das RKI beziehungsweise in dem Fall.
Direktor und Professor.
PD, Doktor Uwe Wichmann vom Robert Koch Institut auf Anfrage eben der Minister äh äh Präsidentenkonferenz. Die Frage beantworten sollte,
und ab welchem Zeitpunkt geimpfte Personen hinreichende Sicherheit nicht infektiös sind, eben das eine Einbeziehung in Testkonzepte möglicherweise absolut wird, hatten wir ja schon. Und was.
Wörtlich gesagt wurde, nachdem eben wie gesagt Tests im Prinzip, nachdem da Prinzip drinsteht in dem
Großteil des Tests eigentlich scheiße sind. Ähm kommt dann aus Public Health Sicht erscheint das Risiko einer Virusübertragung
durch
Impfung nach gegenwärtigen Kenntnisstand in dem Maß reduziert, das geimpfte bei der EPD-Miologie der Erkrankung wahrscheinlich keine wesentliche Rolle mehr spielen
Das Risiko kann durch weitere Vorgaben
Selbstisolierung bei Symptomen weiter einhalten der AH Plus L Regeln zusätzlich reduziert werden. So, ja? Das ist.
Sagen das, was das RKI bestätigt hat und daraus wurde dann, nachdem das RKI bestätigt hat, dass Geimpfte nicht mehr das Virus verbrei.
Obwohl die eigentliche Aussage war.
Also das Maß in dem sie das Virus noch verbreiten können, sei epidemiologisch nicht mehr relevant.
Ja, also es hat keine Auswirkung auf ihre Modellrechnung oder keine nennenswerten Auswirkungen auf ihre Modellrechnung für den weiteren Anstieg oder die Eindämmung der Pandemie, aber es ist eben nicht so, dass sie gesagt haben, kann niemanden mehr infizieren.
Sondern im Gegenteil. Das steht eigentlich genau das Gegenteil äh drin, nämlich da steht drin sozusagen äh das Risiko kann durch weitere Vorgaben, Selbstisolierung.
Symptomen Einhalten der AHL-Regeln zusätzlich reduziert werden, das heißt da steht drin.
Ganz konkret, dass sehr wohl ein Risiko einer Virusübertragung,
nach wie vor besteht, ist es halt reduziert. Es ist halt auch erheblich reduziert, dass halt äh es ist soweit reduziert, dass in einer geimpf
Population sich die Krankheit nicht weiter verbreiten kann. Aber das ist eine völlig andere Geschichte. Äh ob,
sagen ein Geimpfter, jetzt nicht trotzdem in der Lage ist, äh,
froh auf der Bühne zu stehen irgendwo und hundert Leute anzustecken, ja? Das geht nach wie vor. So, also äh da gibt es.
Sagt, hatten wir ja schon. Äh, natürlich ist das Risiko auch reduziert, aber.
Es ist weniger reduziert als durch Masken beispielsweise. Ja? Also
Insofern klar und in Kombination natürlich besser, aber ähm ja, wenn ich sagen bin geimpfter äh ohne Maske ist gefährlicher als dann ungeimpfter Mitmaske,
das kann man äh äh glaube ich äh so konstatieren, äh wenn man, wenn's darum um die Frage geht, äh kann ich mich bei dem anstecken oder nicht.
Ja und das scheint aber ja das also da scheint,
irgendwie eine sehr selektive Wahrnehmung äh offenbar statt zu finden, die ähm wahrscheinlich auch eine eine kulturelle Geschichte ist oder eine eine durch
durch berufliche Prägung, dass man eben als Politiker.
Anders kommuniziert als äh Wissenschaftler des ähm Untereinander tun oder überhaupt generell tun.
So und ja mehr Bildung, war mehr Bildung, bessere Bildung, sage ich mal, das ist halt die.
Wenn man sich die Wissenschaftler im äh in Medien anschaut, also Melanie Brinkmann und so weiter, wenn ich mich mit ich schaue diese Talksendung nicht so gerne, aber man kriegt's ja dann doch immer wieder so die Ausschnitte vorgespült und das ist schon,
schon wirklich fast verzweifelt, ne? Also man kann auch einfach, glaube ich, hier jetzt langsam mal festhalten.
Dieser Mythos, dass die deutsche Politik Wissenschaftsgetrieben sei.
Da würde ich gerne wie so ein Popanz äh herumgetragen wurde im letzten Jahr. Das da kann man einfach mal vergessen. Also das bestenfalls waren das Zufälle.
Leider leider ist es aber auch so, äh dass man nicht
unbedingt ein uneingeschränktes Loblied auf die Wissenschaft äh singen kann. Ich meine, sie sind nach wie vor das Beste, was wir haben, aber äh leider ist
auch sagen, da gibt es auch viele Wissenschaftler, die das, die das äh anprangern ist dieses ganze System,
welche also gerade im Bereich jetzt der Theorien Grundlagenforschung so was dort gefördert wird, das ist halt auch ein sehr stark politisierter Bereich.
Und das ist dann wieder da, wo wo dann wieder Politik, äh, wo dann Wissenschaftler irgendwie versuchen, politisch zu agieren, da gibt's auch Gewisse, die da Talent haben
und dann halt Geld rausholen und das gerade eine interessante Debatte um die Frage, ob man jetzt einen neuen Teilchenbeschleuniger bau
zum Beispiel, nachdem jetzt das Anzern, na ja, die Ergebnisse so ein bisschen deutlich hinter den Erwartungen zurückgeblieben sind und man jetzt konstatieren muss, dass
eigentlich seit vierzig Jahren in der theoretischen Physik in die falsche,
Richtung gearbeitet wurde, das ist zumindest man halt mit Trinktheorien und mit super Symmetrie und so jetzt irgendwie super Theorien aufgestellt hat, die aber scheinbar keinerlei,
Beziehung zur Realität zu haben, scheinen. Ich meine, wir haben's jetzt hier allerdings bei.
Den Gesundheitswissenschaftlern ist einer eine andere äh Situation oder bei Medizin äh als ähm jetzt in der in der Physik, äh aber äh ja grundsätzlich natürlich ist
so 'ne gewisse Skepsis berechtigt nur der wissenschaftliche Prozess
das immer wieder überprüfen und hinterfragen und und verbessern und sagen Peer Reviews und und andere steigern,
doch die Qualität und Verlässlichkeit der Ergebnisse weit mehr als,
irgendwelches Gerede, ja. So oder irgendwelche Bauchgefühle oder so. Ja,
und ähm sagte.
Das mit Ramona Pop war jetzt nur, weil es mir aufgefallen ist, das aber ich habe das aus verschiedenen, so sagen Mündern äh schon gehört und auch diese ganze Überbewertung von Tests, die eben.
Sich auch zeigt. Wie gesagt, diese diese Aussage, das ist halt vor allen Dingen äh,
einen Placebo oder eine eine Beruhigungspille im Zusammenhang mit Öffnungsdebatten. So, das ist die die Hauptwirkung äh.
Aus meiner Sicht. Ja, also Wissenschaft bei aller berechtigten Kritik äh so.
Ist nach wie vor die beste Quelle um rauszufinden.
Was denn so vor sich geht und welche Maßnahmen man denn vielleicht treffen kann, um äh die Zukunft ein bisschen,
besser äh zu gestalten. Ja, so viel äh äh dazu.
Ja eine eine Lösung gerade gibt's da nicht außer wenn ich mit dem Finger drauf zu zeigen und mehr Geld in Bildung zu stehen.
Und bei der Auswahl unserer Politiker vielleicht mehr darauf zu achten.
So äh ja was denn deren intellektuelle Kapazität eigentlich ist.
Wenn er nicht so viel Hoffnung.
Nee, Hoffnung habe ich da auch nicht, aber irgendwie äh egal. Ähm ja.
Ansonsten vielleicht noch die Greifswaldgeschichte, weil ich dazu auch mehrmals gefragt.
Worden bin und auch ähm gefragt wurde, wie um meine meine Einschätzung so bei.
Sagen ja Streit um verfälschte Inzidenzen, so der Landkreis Vorpommern-Greifswald.
Hatte halt seit einem Monat ähm eine zunehmend steigende Meldeverzögerung, die dann,
Anfang April nochmal in ganz neue Höhen gingen, die im Endeffekt in Kombination mit der Art und Weise, wie offiziell beim RKI Inzidenzen berechnet äh werden, dazu geführt hat,
dass die offiziellen Institutionen für den Landkreis Vorpommern-Greifswald weniger als halb so hoch waren, wie sie eigentlich aufgrund der Neuinfektion hätten sein müssen, weil eben die Hälfte der Fälle.
Teilweise über die Hälfte der Fälle einfach aus der Inzidenz rausgefallen sind, weil sie länger als sieben Tage gebraucht haben bis zum RKI, so von Gesundheit, von der Meldung, beim Gesundheitsamt, bis zum RKI, wenn der Fall nicht in sieben Tagen.
Ist, fällt er halt weg bei der Institenzberechnung. Nicht in der Gesamtzahlberechnung aber.
Eben bei der Institutionsberechnung und daraufhin,
kam dann eben ja der der Vorwurf unter anderem vom Kreisverband der Grünen, ja, aber auch anderen gegen den Landrat, die gesagt haben, hier äh Landrat ist CDU.
Michael Sack äh der Verantwortliche und äh dem wurde vorgeworfen jetzt äh ja, dass sie die Zahlen absichtlich manipulieren würden. Und.
Jetzt gab es da eine Äußerung, also der Landrat hat jetzt Donnerstag angekündigt, das Meldeverfahren der.
Neuinfektion umzustellen und das wieder zu.
Bei den Meldeverzug zu verringern und begründet ihn damit wir sind davon ausgegangen, dass wir siebzig Einzelpunkte bei der Befragung von positiv getesteten Menschen auf einmal liefern müssen. So sag,
Tatsächlich sei aber ein weniger umfangreicher Datensatz für die Meldung ausreichend. Das sei bei der Betrachtung der Arbeitsweise im Landkreis zusammen mit dem Lagos, ähm Landesamt führen,
Gesundheit oder so und äh Gesundheit und Soziales, genau. Äh
Das sei bei der Betrachtung eben klar geworden und nun ließe sich die Arbeitsweise der Kontakt nach Verfolgung schneller und effizienter gestaltender Profall deutlich weniger Zeit bis zur Meldung
aufgewendet werden müsse, teilte der Landkreis mit. Zudem solle die Kontaktnachverfolgung künftig enger mit den Mitarbeitern zusammenarbeiten, welche die Meldungen
an das Landesamt senden, so. Und dann wurde ich jetzt gefragt, so ist das jetzt.
Glaubwürdig oder halte ich das äh jetzt für glaubwürdig diese Entschuldigung und ich muss sagen hm ja.
So, ich denke äh das ist plausibel. Klar, ich stick da jetzt nicht so tief.
Drin, aber es entspricht halt doch dem, was ich vermutet habe, dass es da irgendwie Personalwechsel gegeben hat oder irgendwelche anderen Ansprachen vor.
Ja vier bis sechs Wochen und sie irgendwie die Arbeitsweise dort umgestellt hat und ab. Seitdem fing halt an,
ja sich die Fälle dort nach und nach zu stapeln und jetzt.
Anzunehmen, dass das absichtlich passiert ist, müsste da jemand verdammt viel Weitblick,
bewiesen haben und dann aber das Ganze so ungeschickt umgesetzt, dass es halt total aufgefallen,
ist so, also es passt halt schon nicht nicht zusammen, also so viel, ich sag mal, so viel vorausschauendes Handeln.
In der Epidemie wäre äh äh wirklich ungewöhnlich so äh ja äh Plus äh zusammen mit Hahnlons.
Rasiermesser,
was halt besagt, dass ja du nicht Böswilligkeit unterstellen sollst, wo Unfähigkeit als Erklärung völlig ausreicht
ähm äh ja, würde ich sagen, ganz weit nicht hundertprozentig ausschließen, dass da nicht irgendjemand doch,
was äh gemacht hat oder zu manipulieren versucht hat, aber ich halte es für eher.
Unwahrscheinlich, ja? Also das das.
Das passt für mich da äh nicht zusammen. Ich meine, dass dann jetzt politisch darauf hingewiesen wurde.
Ist äh und und das abgestellt wird, ist natürlich zu Recht, weil.
Ja an andere Landkreise kriegen auch gemeldet. Man fragt man sich auch, warum fällt es dem Gesundheitsamt nicht auf, äh dass.
Andere Ämter offensichtlich die ganzen Meldungen.
Am selben Tag noch raushauen können, da gar nichts liegen bleibt. So und bei denen sich dann einen Rückstau von im Schnitt äh glaube ich bis zu vier Tagen oder so aufgebaut hat.
Und ja äh aber da ist es dann wieder so, ich meine, ich will jetzt niemanden,
dissen, aber.
Ist nun mal so, dass auch der öffentliche Dienst gerade in der Provinz manchmal einfach Probleme hat, wirklich Spitzenpersonal dort hinzukriegen,
keine Ahnung, ob das hier der Grund ist, aber was ich halt schon erlebt habe äh
so die sind alle super nett die Leute, also das das Tolle ist so auf dem Land
mit den Ämtern und so, mit denen kann man toll quatschen und die haben Verständnis und der Service, das ist ja eigentlich auch toll, aber wenn du dir dann die Formulare, die sie sich gebastelt haben,
anguckst wo oder irgendwie andere Dinge und Prozesse dann dann ja äh,
deren ja Recht schreibe, Fähigkeiten und so, dann denkt man schon, hm, ja, also auf dem Land ist es halt manchmal nicht so leicht, gutes Personal.
Zu finden. So und äh plus natürlich ist die Leute halt.
Vielleicht auch, also ja äh Urlaub, Krankheit, andere Dinge.
Änderung neuer Vorgesetzter Beförderungen, wie auch immer plus irgendwelche.
Anweisung von oben irgendwelche,
ja Briefe vom RKI oder wie auch immer wo die Leute dann sitzen und interpretieren, was denn das RKI jetzt eigentlich genau von denen will und dann halt ihre Arbeitsprozesse dann so umstellen, dass es
wie in dem Fall nicht läuft, denn dass du vielleicht ein paar Leute, die auch Amt sind, ja im öffentlichen Dienst, dass es auch immer wieder Leute, die haben einfach keinen Bock mehr zu arbeiten
so gar nicht mehr. Jedenfalls nicht an dem, äh, wofür sie eingestellt sind und die Vorgesetzten können da aber nichts dran ändern,
und ja das ergibt dann aus meiner Sicht durchaus kann da so eine Mischung zusammenkommen, wo dann genau eben sowas passiert,
und äh ja.
Von daher sind wir nachsichtig jetzt ein bisschen.
Ja, genau, aber.
Zahlen wieder gefixt.
Ja. Ähm so natürlich haben wir jetzt irgendwie also,
SPD-Politiker Erich von Malotki und irgendwie Hannes Damm.
Physiker und Landtagskandidaten. Den Grünen sagte, wichtigste ist jetzt, dass ab sofort wieder korrekte Institzen gemeldet werden nach über sieben Wochen mit falschen Zahlen. Es ist nur so wieder möglich, die Bevölkerung angemessen zu schützen. So während,
Erich von Malotkidi Begründung für Hanebüchen und unglaubwürdig hält. Ja,
die Erklärung stiel für ein hohes Maß an Innenkompetenz ja. Das kann ich unterschreiben
da ist sicherlich in der Kompetenz im Gange, aber beides geht nicht. Also entweder sie waren jetzt inkompetent und oder sie waren halt irgendwie
oder haben versucht super schlau zu sein und haben halt vor sechs Wochen sich überlegt wie sie jetzt über Ostern halt die Zahlen manipuliert kriegen,
Ich glaube nicht.
Da erwartet man wahrscheinlich auch schon fast so viel von ihnen. Gut Pavel, ich denke, wir sollten mal ähm zum Ende kommen mit dieser Sendung.
Heute alles sehr äh zahllastig.
Demnächst vielleicht äh wieder ein bisschen mehr zu Viren und was sonst noch so ist, aber es war ein bisschen dünner über Ostern, fand ich oder zumindest habe ich nicht das Richtige gesehen. Ähm.
Was bleibt. Äh wir werden voraussichtlich nächste Woche dann mehr Klarheit haben.
Eigentlich alles gerade bewegt, weil was auch immer, jetzt über Ostern, für Effekte passiert sind, sollte sich das langsam wieder einnorden.
Und dann die Woche drauf äh wird's dann halt langsam sportlich mit dem Wiederanlaufenden Schulen und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was wir dann sehen.
Also da ist äh sage mal, äh da ist mittlerweile relativ klar, dass.
Offene Schulen und Kitas mit sinkenden Zahlen nicht vereinbar sind.
Man könnte stattdessen auch die Firmen zumachen äh so, dann könnte man sich's leisten, recht schulen und,
Kitas äh eher offen zu halten, aber Firmen und Schulen und Kitas
zusammen, das geht halt nicht so, ja? Also damit kriegt man einfach die Zahl nicht runter, das kann man halt so festhalten,
und da auch, ah ja, ein habe ich noch äh der Wirtschaftsrat der CDU.
Hat sich geäußert, ja.
Gerne erwähnt, äh immer wieder, beziehungsweise wenn wenn der sich zu Wort meldet, werde ich halt immer hellhörig, weil ähm,
der Wirtschaftsrat der CDU ist nicht, wie man denken würde, irgendwie ein Parteiorgan der CDU, sondern das ist eine private Lobby-Organisation, die,
der CDU nahe steht und wo halt viele CDU-Mitglieder auch Mitglied in dieser Lobbyorganisation sind und was du dort eben machen kannst, ist, wenn's dir da halt kannst da halt Mitglied werden als
Privatperson oder als Firma zahlst du inzwischen tausend und dreißigtausend Euro im Jahr ein Mitgliedsbeitrag und.
Christian halt dafür Facetime mit CDU-Politikern so und ich meine für Bundesminister und Kanzlerin muss dann glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen was drauflegen oder muss dann halt eher in der dreißigtausend Euro Beitragskategorie
sein, aber das ist halt quasi die Organisation, die sicherstellen soll, damit,
in der CDU nicht die Arbeiter die Oberhand gewinnen, sondern dass dort die Unternehmensinteressen halt auch hinreichend bewahr gewahrt bleiben wo es doch
so wenig Unternehmer gibt und so viele Arbeiter, braucht man halt ein Gegengewicht und dafür ist halt dieses Ding äh so ein Teil. Ja
und ähm was,
eben geäußert haben war auch, dass sie halt auf gar keinen Fall einen Lokdown für ähm ja akzeptabel halten, das das geht halt alles nicht, aber am bemerkenswertesten war
dann in dem, in dem Papier, was sie verfasst haben vor einiger Zeit äh war ja, dass Schulen und Kitas aufbleiben müssen, damit die Leute in Ruhe arbeiten gehen können.
So, das ist da gibt es halt eben auch diesen Zusammenhang äh ganz klar auf auf der Seite und jetzt könnte man halt umgekehrt sagen, okay ähm.
Weil wir die Firmen zumachen, dann brauchen die Leute
auch sagen ja da müssten die Kinder äh auch nicht nicht in die Schule oder oder in die Kita und dann ist es alles wunderbar und ja je länger ich mir das anschaue umso umso mehr wird
wird klar, dass einfach unsere Wirtschaft oder unseres Wirtschaftssystem
die mangelnde Bereitschaft in weiten Teilen dort für geeignete Maßnahmen zu sorgen,
der eigentliche Hauptgrund ist und da eben dort ist auch eine politisch.
Entsprechend starke Lobby und Vertretung gibt, ist dann.
Auch ja der Grund, warum wir so gelähmt sind, ist nicht nur, weil unsere Politiker es nicht.
Viele der Politiker es nicht schnallen, sondern weil sie eben auch abhängig sind von bestimmten,
Strukturen und bestimmten
Gruppen der Gesellschaft sich verpflichtet sehen wie zum Beispiel der Automobilindustrie oder eben anderen großen Wirtschaftsbereichen und sicherstellen wollen, dass natürlich zum Wohl aller.
So äh unsere Wirtschaft brummt und läuft und ja dem.
Hat sich aus Sicht dieser Leute eben alles unterzuordnen, nur was sie halt nicht verstehen ist, dass sie im jetzt im Zusammenhang mit der Pandemie äh nicht nur.
Jetzt ja zigtausend Tote auf dem Gewissen äh haben mit auf dem Gewissen haben sie an sich komplett.
Eigene Fleisch schneiden, indem sie halt mit äh ja wirksame Maßnahmen zur Einnehmung der Panimie
bekämpfen so und ich ja und sich dabei auch noch einen schlanken Fuß machen
so. Ja, da wird tun ja alles und so und wir können ja nichts dafür und,
äh wir haben ja hier ganz tolle Sicherheits äh Konzepte und so, haben einige auch und ich sag man kann ja nicht alle Unternehmen über einen Kampf sharen, aber
wer sich fragt, warum äh das nicht so voran
geht oder warum wir keine harten Lockdowns haben, kann halt da auch bestimmte Lobbyorganisationen, die ihr Geld von Unternehmen äh äh erhalten ähm
ganz klar die Ursache
finden und also der Wirtschaftsrat der CDU ist eine davon äh INSM und andere. Das sind halt Leute, die im Moment dazu beitragen, äh ja, dass hier die Institzen
nicht nach unten gehen können, weil sie meinen.
Neue soziale Marktwirtschaft meinst du, ne? Genau.
Genau, weil sie, weil sie eben auch der Meinung sind, eigentlich, dass die Maßnahmen.
Die nötig wären uns mehr schaden würden als das Virus. So. Ja, das ist deren.
Grundsicht und Grundeinstellung und äh ja,
eigentlich näher an, ja, Corona und Wissenschafts äh Leugnern dran ist und ich verstehe auch die Firmen nicht, äh dass die halt äh
in diese Richtung begehen oder das zulassen oder dass das Wollen sagen so so kurzfristig zu planen, aber das hat wiederum auch damit zu tun, die wir nicht kennen.
Paar äh.
Der ganz großen deutschen Wirtschaftsführer auch persönlich und hab ein bisschen Zeit mit denen verbracht und ja und die sind,
alle nicht so von Politik und von Demokratie und so begeistert. Manche sind äh bei manchen geht es sogar bis hin zu einer Politikverachtung äh,
aber zumindest so ist es eher eine ja ähm.
Sagen nicht nur nicht nur Skepsis, sondern Geringschätzung, so, also Geringschätzung demokratischer, politischer Prozesse, das findest du halt oft bei den großen äh äh Wirtschaftsführern, die sagen nicht, denn,
im privaten Wow, geil, dass wir hier so eine Demokratie haben oder so, sondern denen geht halt auch. Also es ist dann auch nicht anders als beim Stammtisch äh und so. Scheiß Politik und.
Ja? Obwohl die halt diejenigen sind, die massiven Einfluss auf die Politik haben zur gleichen Zeit.
Geltend machen. Und das ist vielleicht noch letztes vor allem ein Ding auf äh ähm.
Auf Bundes und Europaebene da konzentrieren die sich, weil dort die eigentlichen Entscheidungen passieren im Land generell oder Landespolitik ist,
in der Regel weniger wirtschaftsfreundlich, beziehungsweise hängt dann so ein bisschen von der Regierung ab, aber generell äh sind sind die Länder so ein bisschen bornierter. Ähm,
Egal. Das war jetzt äh sagen nochmal zum zum Schluss äh sagen noch ein
Kurs noch eine weitere lang ein weiteres Moment, was was aufgetaucht ist
was es uns gerade schwierig macht. Also es ist nicht nur unsere Demokratie und unsere demokratischen Prozesse, sondern auch, dass diese halt
sagen, missbraucht werden von Interessengruppen, um äh ja wirksame Maßnahmen zu verhindern und,
eigene Interessen auf Kosten der Allgemeinheit äh dort politisch Priorität zu verschaffen.
Also Vizepräsident ist im Wirtschaftsrat der CDU e. V. Friedrich Merz.
Nein. Ah äh.
Na ja interessante Einblicke äh auf jeden Fall. Ähm ist klar, dass.
Hier die Wirtschaft in Anführungsstrichen so ein bisschen äh der entscheidende Punkt zu sein scheint in jeder Hinsicht. Also es ist einfach schwierig in Deutschland.
Äh Maßnahmen zu beschließen, die ja von der Wirtschaft abgelehnt werden, egal ob das jetzt irgendwie sinnvoll ist oder nicht.
Es ist also letztlich ist es der Dreh und Angelpunkt äh dieser Pandimie sowohl was.
Das Verbreiten des Virus angeht als auch äh sagen der politische Einfluss oder politische Druck, der dort äh gemacht wird, also beides,
ist ja kommt dem Virus wirklich zugute bei uns.
So, jetzt probier ich's aber nochmal. Hier ähm zum Ende zu kommen. Ähm ich denke, wir sind jetzt durch für diese Woche.
Ich habe aber auch noch was zu äh plaggen und ich weiß gar nicht, ob es dir schon äh aufgefallen ist. Ich habe äh in der Woche noch einen anderen Podcast veröffentlicht äh in meinem anderen Kanal, im Forschergeist.
Und dort habe ich ein Gespräch geführt mit Andrea Torn, die hatte ich hier auch schon mal erwähnt. Und zwar ist sie diejenige, die diese Corona Bares.
Ins Leben gerufen hat, das also eine Gruppe von Strukturbiologen, die sich ähm ja das Virus mal ganz genau anschauen.
Sprich die pflegen tatsächlich und überprüfen diese gesamten,
Modelle des Virus, also wirklich die Molekularen Strukturen, die äh Strukturen, die tatsächlichen Molekularenstrukturen, der Proteine, die dieses Virus ausmachen.
Und ähm ja machen da so eine Art.
Manueller Überprüfung. Ja, also es sind so Strukturbiologen, so eine so eine Sonderdisziplin, die normalerweise nicht so beachtet wird, die aber an dieser Stelle wirklich eine eine große Rolle zu äh spielen scheint.
Weil die sich eben tatsächlich äh das Ganze ganz genau anschauen. Da kommen verschiedene Techniken zum Einsatz. Da kommt unter anderem Christoph Christallographie
zum Einsatz, also wird so in großen äh Maschinen, diese Moleküle.
Kristallisiert und äh dann eben entsprechend Elektrodenmikroskopen angeschaut und äh dann wird eben tatsächlich auf Basis dieser Ergebnisse hier so dreidimensional. Das hat tatsächliche Molekülskelett.
Modelliert. Und dabei stellt man dann eben überhaupt erstmal fest, okay, was hängt hier eigentlich mit was zusammen
und sie nehmen auch unsere daran haben sie auch am Anfang angefangen, haben sich wirklich die Modelle, die andere gemacht haben von dem Spike-Protein et cetera äh und sind das also wirklich haarklein
durchgegangen und die backen das sozusagen auf so einer strukturellen Ebene und und äh haben dann eben der Öffentlichkeit entsprechende.
Änderungen auch bereitgestellt und sehr viel der anderen Forschung, auch der medizinische Forschung beruft sich mittlerweile auf diese Modelle. Ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz spannende Sendung.
Ähm, wie gesagt, Link findet ihr in Shonots, Forschergeist, Forschergeist äh DE, das ist ein Podcast, den ich zusammen mit dem Stifterverband für die deutsche Wissenschaft mache.
Und ja, der schon länger mal wieder ein Update brauchte und das ist jetzt da. Und ich denke, das könnte euch interessieren.
Sie sie gehört also zu den Proteinfaltern.
Ja, sie faltet sie nicht, sie sie erfaltet sie halt
sie schaut sich halt an wie die ähm diese ganzen Strukturen sind. Das ist eine tolle Geschichte, weil das eben auch so ein.
Also ein so ein aus so einem Spaßprojekt eigentlich hervorgegangen ist. Das sind alles so Studentengruppen, die es dann auch international gefunden haben. Also, ist jetzt nicht nur was die Forschung, die dort.
Äh getrieben wird, interessant, einfach auch ähm forschungspolitisch ganz interessant und deswegen ist es im Forschergastpodcast auch wunderbar aufgehoben, der sich hier nämlich genau um solche Fragen auch,
normalerweise dreht, ne?
Sehr schön, wenn ich mal, wenn ich mal reinhören.
Dann habe ich ähm auch noch äh übers Wochenende vor allem die letzten Tage hm viel Fummelei gemacht an der äh Webseite und endlich mal was finalisiert, was ich schon länger machen wollte
und zwar.
Lasse ich ja hier auch bei UKW schon seit Anfang an und auch bei meinen anderen Podcasts mittlerweile eine automatische Transkription mitlaufen.
Warum? Manuelle Transkription ist relativ aufwendig, zeitaufwendig und damit auch äh kostenintensiv sowas ähm.
Lasse ich machen für den Forschergeist Podcast, also beim Forschergast Podcast gibt's von allem Transkripte und diese Transkripte sind halt.
Handgeklöppelt und von daher halt extrem akkurat.
Ja, also das sind so richtige, so richtige Transkripte, aber jetzt für die Masse der anderen Podcasts ist das nicht äh zu leisten, aber es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit diese Maschinen-Learning-Basierten Dienste.
Die doch erhebliche Fortschritte gemacht haben
zwar absehbar, dass das irgendwann ganz brauchbar sein wird. Ich habe so den Eindruck, man befindet sich jetzt so, na ja, man man
man durchschreitet so langsam dieses Ankenne Valley, ja? Also es ist sozusagen du siehst so ein Transkript schon noch an, dass es äh automatisch erzeugt wurde, weil immer wieder so blöde Fehler drin sind.
Astra Sinnika.
Was auch immer, also du kannst im Prinzip in dem Moment, wo ein Wort auch nur so halbwegs äh genuschelt wird, so, dann sind solche,
Systeme so ein bisschen an der an der Grenze dessen, was sie leisten können. Auf der anderen Seite war ich auch schon häufiger, sehr überrascht.
Was alles richtig und akkurat erkannt wurde.
Auf jeden Fall hat es mittlerweile die Qualität, dass es eben brauchbar ist. Also es ist auf jeden Fall gut, um bestimmte
Stellen wieder zu finden, bestimmte Begriffe äh aufzusuchen und ich hoffe, die werden auch noch besser. Aber damit die auch ordentlich nutzbar sind, ähm.
Gibt's die ja schon seit längerem äh im Webplayer, also wenn man sich den Podcast auf der Webseite anhört, dann gibt's da so ein, so ein, so ein Transkriptionstab,
dann läuft das Transkript so mit, das ist natürlich auch super, wenn man das sozusagen auch parallel lesen will, sagen wir mal, man kann vielleicht nicht so gut Deutsch und lernt das noch,
äh kann man sich halt so einen Podcast so anhören und nebenbei quasi den Text mitlaufen lassen. Das funktioniert natürlich dann bei Forschergeist besonders gut, weil das dann eben immer auch das Transkript dann auch immer das Wort
das Wort anzeigt, was auch eigentlich gesagt werden sollte, sind, wenn's mal nicht so korrekt ausgesprochen wurde.
Ähm aber damit man eben auch die Sendung gut nachschlagen kann, gibt's jetzt auch so ein Transkript zum Runterladen in äh als HTML-Datei. Das habe ich jetzt gerade übers Wochenende gebaut,
Das ist jetzt auch bei UKW drin, also unter dem Player findet ihr so einen Link,
Da kann man sich dann die Transkripte äh so runterladen und dann habt ihr das so als eine Stand-Alone hat hier Meldatei und könnt dort die Sendung quasi auch nachlesen oder Stellen finden und ihr könnt auf eine beliebige,
draufklicken, dann geht wiederum die UKW Webseite aus und der.
Positioniert sich automatisch schon mal an der richtigen Stelle und man kann im Prinzip dann von dort auch gleich weiter hören.
Ist alles ganz nett. Genau und damit das auch mal alle finden und benutzen und ausprobieren können, erwähne ich das an dieser Stelle.
Ja, also ich fand das auch schon teilweise recht nützlich, dass Alte, die alten Transkripte äh schon, aber,
Neue, was ich jetzt gesehen habe, das ist schon verdammt gut. Also wenn man da jetzt,
glaube ich klar und deutlich.
Reinsprechen würde die ganze Zeit dann äh käme da auch fast perfekter Text bei raus vor dem.
Wenigen Fachworten oder Spezialbegriffen mal abgesehen, aber ich finde das ist schon unglaublich gut zumal. Ich selbst mit Spracherkennung äh oft.
Irgendwie Probleme hatte. Also ich habe jede Spracherkennung, die ich ausprobiert habe, so über viele, viele Jahre hinweg äh hatte.
Doch eine ganze Menge Probleme und ähm irgendwie mich zu verstehen, aber das ist natürlich zum einen viel besser geworden und ja und als ich ich war auf jeden Fall schwer beeindruckt davon.
Wie gut, dass es wie wie viele auch schwierige Worte und manchmal sind ja auch und Genuschel und so und selbst selbst das kriegt er ganz gut hin.
Auch die Ams werden mittlerweile gut erkannt. Genau.
Ja, das war's dann eigentlich auch aus dem Maschinenraum.
An der Stelle möchte ich mich auch nochmal für die zahlreichen Unterstützer der Mieterebene ähm bedanken, die dafür sorgen, dass der Spendener nicht unter eins fällt.
Ganz wichtig,
und ansonsten bedanken wir uns für eure Aufmerksamkeit, wir machen Dienstag wieder unsere Clubhausrunde, wer Lust hat, damit uns äh zu quatschen, herzlich willkommen. Ansonsten nächste Woche nächstes UKW Korona äh Wickli.
Bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut, ciao.